67 documents marked as confidential 92
marked secret 25 marked top secret these
are what the FBI said were inside 15
boxes retrieved by the national archives
in January from former president Donald
Trump's Mar-A-Lago home they were handed
over after linked the efforts to secure
Trump's presidential records and that's
when they said oh my gosh this is a lot
bigger than just a presidential records
act violation this could be a classified
information National Security risk and
so we need to bring the justice
department in on this it triggered an
FBI search of the Florida property in
August where the justice department says
even more highly classified documents
were found the standards around
classification and declassification are
key to the federal investigation into
Trump and his defense here's how that
process works including what Authority
the president has and doesn't have
the Constitution gives the president as
commander-in-chief authority to decide
what should be classified and recent
presidents have managed this by writing
an Executive Order Detailing the rules
around the classification and
declassification process it's
essentially been the same for decades
Bush really just updated Clinton's order
Obama just updated bushes and that's
still the current procedure neither
Trump nor Biden released new ones the
order gives the authority to decide what
should be classified to people called
Original classifiers they're folks like
the director of intelligence and other
higher-ups the executive branch which
includes the military employs more than
4 million people less than 1500 of them
have this important designation
they write out classification guides
deciding what information should be
classified and to what level that guide
would be distributed to other members of
the agency so they would know to label
documents with the right classification
and know whom they could and couldn't
distribute it to
confidential is the lowest
classification level information that
could cause damage to National Security
the next level is secret then top secret
there's also additional classifications
like special access programs that only
limited people can view the bin Laden
raid for example would have been a
special Access program there's also
sensitive compartmented information
which contains details about intelligent
sources and methods basically
information from spies they can only be
used and stored in special secured
facilities or Skiffs the same goes with
special access program files
both these kinds of Highly classified
materials were found in documents from
Mar-A-Lago
when marking a document containing
classified information the author must
include which original classifier has
deemed it classified and why and
directions on how it should be
Declassified it can be automatic after a
certain date or after an event takes
place but it generally can't be more
than 25 years from its creation
according to the latest executive order
if information is to be Declassified
earlier like what Trump says he did that
Authority lies with the same people who
could classify it in the first place the
original classifiers and the president
and the procedure is similar typically a
declassification guide would be written
and sent out the classified documents
would then also be changed to show that
the information was Declassified and
it's important to note that this
Authority resides in the position not
the individual who holds that position
so if an original classifier retires
that person no longer has the authority
to classify or declassify but whoever
takes their position does this includes
the president
the President also doesn't have
authority over all classified
information like nuclear weapons are
classified by law and any information
shared by other countries can only be
Declassified by them
here's where it gets a little
complicated in regard to Trump his
lawyers claim that he broadly
Declassified a range of materials
suggesting that any material brought to
Mar-A-Lago wasn't classified but there's
no written record of that blanket
declassification a former aide argues he
did it verbally similar to what he did
in 2020. in October of 2020 president
Trump put out for the world to see a
sweeping declassification order that is
the precedent that the president of the
United States is allowed to operate
under but in 2020 when journalists sued
to obtain those supposed Declassified
records they were denied Trump's Chief
of Staff wrote in court testimony that
Trump's statements were not
self-executing declassification orders
meaning Trump said it but didn't
actually want to declassify the
documents in almost every case we have
seen the court say look we understand
the president said this in public but he
hasn't gone through any of the
procedures for declassifying this in a
similar case in 2020 the Court ruled
that while the president has brought
authority to classify and declassify
declassification cannot occur unless
designated officials follow specified
procedures basically the president has
to do more than just declare it
Declassified so the lack of any evidence
that they actually went through those
procedures makes it really hard in my
view to prove to a court that any of
this was actually Declassified even
though there's a good argument Mr Mr
Trump may have had that Authority when
he was president the FBI search warrant
cited several laws surrounding the
handling of documents not necessarily
just classified ones this case is isn't
just about classified documents this is
about the unlawful retention and
potentially mistreatment or manipulation
of a whole range of government records
the investigation that stems from that
August search could widen to more
classified information but that will
involve the courts deciding if those
documents really were classified